warum tue ich mir diese scheiße mann das
sahne bad sahne ist mein leben family
stories ihr wisst wahrscheinlich jetzt
schon was das für eine dumme reaction
heute immer wieder wird denn ich habe ja
in letzter zeit mal wieder ein bisschen
häufiger auf serien wie hilfe
beispielsweise reagiert und vor einigen
monaten habe ich noch sehr häufig auf
dumme reagiert und doppel war teil von
der serie family stories und die haben
jetzt diese folge herausgebracht von
daher will ich sagen wir vor uns das
gleich in die saane hier einstürzen
werfen wir zuvor noch einen kurzen weg
in die kommentare das ist einfach mega
die lebensmittelverschwendung wer findet
diese sendung auch so widerlich und kann
beim schauen nichts essen aber muss es
nicht trotzdem immer anschauen jeder
normale mensch bringt mit graffiti dani
sprüht mit sprühsahne die alte hat so
einen gewaltigen schaden dass andreas
von frauen tauschen noch normal dagegen
ist ich denke mir gerade nur so
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
warum gucke ich diesen geistigen
durchfall überhaupt schon der titel hat
mich denken lassen will stufen allen
guten geistern verlassen
ja das denke ich auch aber wir schauen
uns das ganze trotzdem mal an los geht's
mit dem video meine lieben freunde wir
sind wieder an irgendeiner am wohnung
gesehen schon sahne auf dem boden und
das ist die menge an seine die ich in
meinem leben bisher gegessen habe was
macht die denn mit so viel sahne macht
die wachen auf
einzeln recht dran probierte es jetzt
autor und schüttet es dann in einen
das soll glaube ich ihr sahne bad werden
sie macht sich selbst hunger schlagsahne
maschine dann endlich probieren konnte
richtig die sau raus reingefallen
da ist so richtig in seinem rausch
reingefallen
ach du grüne neune es ist doch nicht ihr
ernst
also ich meine wie bereits gesagt habe
ich ja damals schon sehr häufig auf
doppelfolgen reagiert im anschluss an
die ganze serie als finale habe ich dann
tatsächlich doppel im reallife getroffen
die ein interview geführt und damit
aufgefallen ok bommel ist nicht dumm
sondern dominique und das war wirklich
alles alles nur gespielt also vermutlich
ist das ja auch alles gespielt das
solltet ihr euch immer vor augen führen
ich möchte hier keineswegs irgendwelche
personen beleidigen oder irgendwas
sondern es geht mir lediglich um die
gespielte rolle die hier von dieser
personen namens heißt die eigentlich
wirklich da nie
diese leute von rtl am sich
wahrscheinlich einfach gedacht wir
machen wir eine folge wo irgend so eine
frau süchtig ist nach sahne und als
namen nehmen wir einfach dani sahne muss
ganz ehrlich sagen rtl ich habe großen
respekt vor eurer kreativität bei so was
war da nie frist direkt nachschub das
reicht nicht perfekt doch 40 packung
geil alles ende in der schale füllt
perfekt ab in lockerer so perfekt fahren
machen
ja ich war so schon gut geschmeckt weil
ich hab dann gedacht so gut nimmst du
seine kreuze was einfach heilige saanen
draußen
jahre werde
einige saale
die einfache und verzaubern die so ein
bisschen
und dann habe ich einfach mal heilige
sahne hergestellt
wir kommentieren so krebs habt ihr die
kraft und riet mir diese schuld war
sie nimmt jetzt kräuter segne diese
kräuter habe ding und betet und macht
jetzt heilige sahne daraus das ist doch
war das ist doch nicht wahr
ich fand schon schlimm als als sommer da
ihr fleisch wurst gemacht hast du es
ganz gut an
[Musik]
wer ist überhaupt der heilige constantin
jetzt halt irgendwie der saane kräuter
gott oder was als maske irgendwie fühlt
sich die haut viel entspannter an klar
ich muss man die sahne war nun besser
was die folge war ja bis jetzt schon
schlimm genug aber wir sind ja nicht nur
zum titel gekommen sie muss dass seine
badia noch machen ganzen körper
jetzt fühlt sich das aus ihrer weide
maschine
in einem wiederum ganz allein an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin zurück weshalb hast
steht dann wieder als ich mein ohr mein
gott ich weiß
immer hier dann irgendwie haut in diesem
video schon clowns musik im hintergrund
und finde das lustig aber ich habe noch
kein mal in dieser folge gelacht
weil
das ist einfach traurig
da will ich nicht darüber lachen ich
weiß das ist alles logisch spielt ich
weiß es ich weiß aber wer kommt denn auf
so eine rolle in einer tv serie
[Musik]
ein problem habe ich noch den 2
dirk nowitzki ja genau ich musste schon
irgendwie gucken dass ich das geld für
zusammen kommen scheint das schlimmste
was mir passieren kann sich überhaupt
nicht möchte dass das der leser also man
weiß immer noch nicht genau wer dirk ist
aber anscheinend schuldet sie dirk 500
euro und der dirk will entweder die 500
euro oder dem tier die saale maschine
weg und das wäre natürlich horror
schwächeln eine idee hätte ich dann noch
restaurants und die brauchen immer mal
sahne verkauft denen die sahne in der du
schon gebadet hat das wird locker er
will jedes restaurant art wollen
komischer vorbei ausgeliefert ist was
tolles müssen nicht mal einkaufen gehen
und selbst irgendwann haben die arbeit
nicht mehr
das erwarten sind fange ich mal
angemacht ja also das schlägt ja zehn
fliegen mit 30 klappen es ist eine
restaurant dann haben wir sicher einen
großen bedarf an seine frau sich
beständig frei haus geliefert zu
bekommen und jetzt wird wieder alles
weitere die ihren komischen saale
dingsda reingepackt genau und alles
schön abgefüllt wahnsinn
also ich mir fällt nichts mehr ein
also kann ich jetzt mal durchhören
einmal dann voll gefüllt hattest du
vielleicht los und dann geht es in den
restaurants ja komm mit vollen taschen
nach hause und lerne ja so eine super
idee flüchten
[Musik]
andere leute gehen mit ihren hunden
gassi oder gehen spazieren mit ihrem
ehemann
doch die dani geht mit ihren fünf seiner
heimat spazieren ich wenig wissen wir
auf die in diesem video schon klatschen
du jetzt immer glauben ja ich hab meine
frage sind noch exakt bestimmt auch in
sahne zu tun haben jetzt habe ich hier
im angebot für sich wirklich frisches
sahen aus köln dabei
[Musik]
es war so klar dass heute wieder in köln
spielt ich wurde in köln das ist eine
wirklich entspannte stadt zum leben ich
mag köln über alles ich finde es mit
einer der coolsten städte in deutschland
aber je bescheuerte hilf mir volk oder
family stories folge alles spielt in
köln galt dabei dem wetter mein gott und
jetzt gibt sie auch noch sie will dass
er wirklich verkaufen und dann zeigt sie
dass man das essen kann und die damit
ihren bloßen dreckigen finger rein ich
kann ihnen auch gerne hier ja super hat
außerdem gute verpackungstechnik dass
diese art zwei mal die finger april
überreicht dann getötet
ja wie soll ich das verkaufen wie soll
ich das verwerten sie können das ja dann
umfüllen einer schüssel oder
[Musik]
wir haben sie in pusan zehn liter
keine ahnung wie dieses machen aber sie
können es ja ich meinen umfüllen in der
schüssel die sind ja eine kneipe denn da
kann man ja sahen in der schüssel gut
kaufen
also ganz ehrlich ich muss wirklich
sagen ich finde es bemerkenswert dass du
dein hobby mit der sahne so toll und
öffentlich aus lebst aber ich glaube du
wirst keine abnehmer finden allerdings
schauen wir uns das ganze in den
nächsten reaction auf dani und ihr seine
bahn nennt an dieser stelle ich das
heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ich weiß wir sind noch
nicht einmal bei der hälfte dieses
videos angekommen bei dieser sahne bad
folge hiervon family stories aber meine
gehirnzellen sagen wir schon wieder luca
du brauchst mal wieder vier tage pause
von dieser serie von daher werde ich
meine heutige reaktion gefallen hat und
ihr wollt dass ich in einigen tagen auf
den rest des videos sie reagiere dann
hat es auf jeden fall einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und bei 50.000
likes wenn ihr diese anzahl schafft dann
kommt in einigen tagen vielleicht in der
woche keine ahnung meine reaktion auf
die restlichen acht minuten dieser folge
falls noch keine abonnenten von einem
kanal dann könnt ihr gern unter dem joch
abonnieren klicken können auch gern auf
die glocke klicken dann verpasste direkt
das video nicht wenn ich das dann noch
mal habe ich sagen
so meine gene sind tot ich weiß nicht
wie es euch geht aber ich muss jetzt
erstmal zum psychologen
[Musik]